[Music]
how are you greeted by cristiano casares with
her brief newscast on kirchner in
spanish officers from the
las vegas metropolitan police department are still on
the trail of suspects
in a shooting inside a minstrel one
person died and three were injured
when they  opened fire inside manish
go up der vaart after
3am saturday officers
say this shooting happened after a fight
anyone with information on
this incident is asked to
contact crime stoppers the
phone there on your screen  7 023 85 55
A Metropolitan Police officer
had his first court hearing
Monday morning Police believe
Caler Waters is linked to an
armed robbery at one of the
gambling houses inside the Rio He Hotel and Casino
has been a subway officer since
2015 for bowden station
ilustrado's investigative team
also reports that he may be involved
involved in two robberies plus one at the
red rock resort on november 12 and
another at our three fences
and on 2 15 on january 6
more than 227,000 dollars were connected to
the american lung association this
year 400 athletes joined the  challenge
to climb 108 floors of the iconic
property the fastest I heard this
27-year-old software from male has
already met this challenge I heard this about
1,455 steps in a period of 6
minutes and 57 seconds you have it on your
screen congratulations and we start the
week  with a sunny day and with
pleasant temperatures here we
present the forecast with several
sunny days and see the temperatures
little by little they will rise almost hitting 80
degrees but do not trust the
temperatures could drop again
after these weeks today christian
cancels with his fierce  informative go
news now to espanyol good day
[Music]